Today, we have this story for you about cars-- American cars. And like a lot of stories about American cars, this one is more tragedy than comedy, although there is some comedy in there, too. The good news, of course, about American cars is that American cars are getting better, especially in the last few years. You've probably heard that.
今天我们为你带来关于汽车的故事——美国汽车。像许多关于美国汽车的故事一样，这个故事悲剧成分多于喜剧，尽管其中也确实有一些喜剧色彩。当然，关于美国汽车的好消息是它们正在变得越来越好，尤其是在过去几年里。你可能已经听说过了。
Well, at Ford, the Ford Fusion-- Consumer Reports named it a better car than the Toyota Camry and Honda Accord a few years ago. I think that was a major turning point.
嗯，就福特而言，几年前《消费者报告》将福特Fusion评为比丰田凯美瑞和本田雅阁更好的车。我认为那是一个重要的转折点。
Michelle Krebs has been covering the auto industry for 35 years. She's now at autotrader.com. She says the reason American cars finally improved--
米歇尔·克雷布斯报道汽车行业已有35年了。她现在在autotrader.com工作。她说美国汽车最终得以改进的原因是——
I think when you're on the brink of possible extinction, it wakes people up, and they started changing things. But that's what it took. I mean, that's why Ford came out with the Ford Fusion. They spent $23 billion-- borrowed $23 billion, because they were almost out of business.
我认为当你处于可能灭绝的边缘时，它会唤醒人们，他们开始做出改变。但这就是代价。我的意思是，这就是福特推出福特Fusion的原因。他们花费了230亿美元——借了230亿美元，因为他们几乎要倒闭了。
So basically, it's deathbed conversions.
所以基本上，这是临终前的皈依。
That's a good way to describe it. They decided, we have got to bet the ranch on building great cars that people really want to buy. They're still not all the way there yet. I mean, I think that's the simple fact of the matter. There's been progress, but it's been spotty.
这是一个很好的描述方式。他们决定，我们必须孤注一掷，制造人们真正想买的好车。他们还没完全做到。我的意思是，我认为这就是事实。虽然有进步，但并不均衡。
How spotty? When Consumer Reports rated the top 10 most reliable car brands this year, only one was American. 9 were foreign. 4 of the top 5, no surprise, were Japanese-- Toyota, Honda, Mazda, and Lexus.
多不均衡？当《消费者报告》今年评选出十大最可靠汽车品牌时，只有一家是美国品牌。9家是外国品牌。前五名中有四家毫无悬念是日本品牌——丰田、本田、马自达和雷克萨斯。
Why are most American cars still not as good as foreign cars? Why is it still taking Detroit so long to learn this lesson? It's not like this reliability problem just snuck up on them, right?
为什么大多数美国汽车仍然不如外国汽车？为什么底特律学习这个教训花了这么长时间？这不是说可靠性问题突然袭击了他们，对吧？
General Motors, the biggest American car maker, started losing market share 50 years ago. Back in the 1960s, GM sold over half the cars in the United States, and then that number just slid lower and lower and lower for decades, until now, it's 18% of all cars sold in the US.
通用汽车作为美国最大的汽车制造商，50年前就开始失去市场份额了。早在20世纪60年代，通用汽车在美国的销量超过了汽车总销量的一半，此后这个数字几十年来一直不断下滑，直到现在，它只占美国汽车总销量的18%。
Today's program came out of a question that we had here at the radio show. We genuinely did not understand why American car makers waited until they were nearly extinct-- two of them bankrupt, one of them nearly bankrupt. Why didn't they get on the ball and start making reliable cars that could compete with the Japanese decades ago?
今天的节目源于我们广播节目组的一个问题。我们真的不明白为什么美国汽车制造商要等到几乎灭绝时才采取行动——其中两家破产，一家濒临破产。为什么他们几十年前没有打起精神，开始制造能与日本汽车竞争的可靠汽车呢？
It seemed like, OK, you're running a business. You're losing sales in such a huge way. Why wouldn't you change? It really made no sense.
看起来就像是，好吧，你在经营一家企业。你的销售额流失得如此严重。为什么你不做出改变？这真的完全说不通。
And we looked around for an explanation, and we learned about this one car factory in California. Here.
我们四处寻找解释，后来了解到了加利福尼亚州的一家汽车工厂。就在这里。
What happened at this factory not only illustrates some very interesting answers to that question, it captures a lot of what went wrong in the American car business in the last 35 years. This is a plant in Fremont, California, called NUMMI. NUMMI stands for New United Motor Manufacturing Incorporated.
这家工厂发生的事情不仅揭示了那个问题的一些非常有趣的答案，还概括了过去35年美国汽车业出错的许多原因。这就是位于加利福尼亚州弗里蒙特的一家工厂，名为NUMMI。NUMMI代表新联合汽车制造公司。
A modern car plant, by the way, sounds a lot like a casino. The automated gear plays these little songs to let you know that it's running. Driverless robotic carts glide up and down the aisles like R2D2 delivering doors and other parts. Their song is supposed to warn you that they're coming.
顺便说一句，现代化的汽车工厂听起来很像赌场。自动化设备会播放这些小曲子，让你知道它在运转。无人驾驶的机器人小车像R2D2一样在过道上来回穿梭，运送车门和其他零件。它们的曲子是为了警告你它们要过来了。
The story of this particular factory is actually a famous story among car people. It's taught at business schools. NUMMI was opened in 1984 by GM and Toyota together. The two companies decided that this would be a place that they would build cars with each other.
这家特定工厂的故事在汽车圈其实是一个著名的故事。它被商业学校当作教材。NUMMI由通用汽车和丰田公司于1984年共同创立。这两家公司决定在这里共同制造汽车。
And if it seems strange to you that two competitors would do this, it seemed strange at the time, also. A headline in Car and Driver about the partnership read, "Hell Freezes Over." But both companies had their reasons. We'll get to those.
如果两个竞争对手这样做让你感到奇怪，那么当时大家也觉得奇怪。《汽车与驾驶者》杂志上一篇关于此次合作的头条标题写道：“地狱结冰了”。但两家公司都有自己的理由。我们稍后会讲到。
At NUMMI, Toyota showed GM all of its secrets. Showed it exactly how it made some of the best-built, most reliable cars in the world back then. GM, at the time, hoped to take these lessons from NUMMI and carry them into all their other plants, all over the country and over the world. That was the 1980s.
在NUMMI，丰田向通用展示了它所有的秘密。准确展示了它在当时是如何制造出世界上一些制造工艺最精良、最可靠的汽车的。通用汽车当时希望将从NUMMI学到的这些经验应用到全国乃至全世界的所有其他工厂中。那是20世纪80年代。
And then, well, you know, it didn't go well. GM was one of the car makers who went bankrupt. US taxpayers, you and I, we bailed them out for $50 billion.
然后，嗯，你知道，情况并不乐观。通用汽车是破产的汽车制造商之一。美国纳税人，你和我，我们以500亿美元救助了他们。
And NUMMI closed. This GM plant that seemed like it might be able to teach American car makers how to catch up to their competitors-- it stopped making cars for GM. The sounds that you're hearing right now-- they were recorded in 2010, in the last months before GM shuttered the place, on April Fools' Day that year.
接着NUMMI关闭了。这家通用汽车的工厂本来看起来或许能教美国汽车制造商如何追赶竞争对手——它停止了为通用制造汽车。你现在听到的这些声音——是2010年，在通用汽车关闭该工厂（即当年愚人节）前的最后几个月里录制的。
Back then, we put together this story that we're about to play for you today. For a few months before NUMMI closed, Frank Langfitt, who at the time was NPR's automotive correspondent, and one of our producers, Brian Reed, travelled around the country talking to GM workers and managers about what had happened at NUMMI. General Motors and the UAW-- they are secretive cultures. But as you're going to hear, people were blunt when they talked to Frank about this. They were blunt in a way that you rarely hear with auto executives and UAW reps when they're being interviewed by the press.
当时，我们整理了这个我们今天准备为你播放的故事。在NUMMI关闭前的几个月里，当时担任美国国家公共电台汽车记者的弗兰克·朗菲特和我们的制片人之一布莱恩·里德，在全国各地走访，与通用汽车的工人和管理人员谈论NUMMI到底发生了什么。通用汽车和全美汽车工人联合会（UAW）——它们都是秘密文化。但正如你即将听到的，人们在和弗兰克谈论这件事时非常直率。他们那种直率是你在新闻媒体采访汽车高管和工会代表时很少听到的。
Act One of our show is going to be about the rise of NUMMI. Act Two is where we get the answer to our question-- what prevented GM from learning from NUMMI for so many years? For WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Our show today produced with our colleagues at NPR News.
我们节目的第一幕将是关于NUMMI的兴起。第二幕我们将得到问题的答案——究竟是什么阻碍了通用汽车多年来向NUMMI学习？这里是WBEZ芝加哥电台的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。我们今天的节目是与我们在NPR新闻的同事合作制作的。
And now it is my pleasure to turn the story over to Frank Langfitt.
现在，我很高兴将这个故事交给弗兰克·朗菲特。
When NUMMI was conceived, General Motors was far and away the world's largest car company. Its US market share was seven times that of Toyota. But each company had a problem that the other company could help them solve.
当NUMMI构想出来时，通用汽车无疑是世界上最大的汽车公司。它的美国市场份额是丰田的七倍。但每家公司都有一个对方可以帮助解决的问题。
On GM's side, the problem was small cars. Under government emission guidelines, General Motors had to build them, but they always lost money for GM, and they were lousy quality. So Toyota suggested a joint venture that offered two things. First, Toyota would build a quality small car for GM-- one that would finally turn a profit.
在通用汽车方面，问题是小型车。根据政府的排放准则，通用汽车必须制造这些车，但它们总是让通用亏钱，而且质量很差。所以丰田建议建立合资企业，提供两样东西。首先，丰田将为通用制造一款高质量的小型车——一款最终能盈利的汽车。
And the second thing was, we have this thing called the Toyota production system, and it produces the quality you see. We could teach you the Toyota production system.
第二件事是，我们有一种叫丰田生产体系的东西，它能产生你所看到的质量。我们可以教你丰田生产体系。
Jeffrey Liker is a professor of industrial engineering at the University of Michigan. He's been studying Japanese auto manufacturing, including NUMMI, since the 1980s, and wrote a book about it called The Toyota Way . He says even though Toyota was offering GM something quite remarkable-- to teach a competitor its secrets, to show them exactly how Toyota achieved such phenomenal reliability-- GM wasn't that interested.
杰弗里·莱克是密歇根大学的工业工程教授。自20世纪80年代以来，他一直在研究日本汽车制造业，包括NUMMI，并写了一本关于它的书《丰田之路》。他说，尽管丰田向通用提供了一些非常了不起的东西——教竞争对手它的秘密，准确展示丰田是如何实现如此惊人的可靠性的——但通用对此并不怎么感兴趣。
Some people in GM, I think, had some foresight to realize this is important. I think for many of the senior leaders, it was more, OK, well, maybe I'll learn something, maybe I won't, but it won't hurt.
我想通用汽车里有些人确实有远见，意识到这很重要。但我认为对于许多高层领导来说，更多的是，好吧，也许我会学到点什么，也许不会，但这也不会有什么坏处。
Why wouldn't they be really interested in the Toyota production system? Because at that point, wasn't Toyota building higher quality cars?
为什么他们对丰田生产体系不那么感兴趣？因为在那时，丰田不是已经在制造质量更高的汽车了吗？
Toyota was building higher quality cars. I'm not sure it was 100% accepted at that time by senior management that Japanese quality was really better.
丰田确实在制造质量更高的汽车。我不确定当时高级管理层是否100%接受日本的质量真的更好。
Why?
为什么？
I think there was pride and defensiveness. I'm proud because I'm the biggest automaker in the world. I've been the best. I've dominated the market. You can't teach me anything, you little Japanese company.
我想是因为骄傲和防御心理。我感到自豪，因为我是世界上最大的汽车制造商。我一直是最棒的。我统治了市场。你教不了我什么，你这个日本小公司。
I'm John Shook. Toyota and Toyota City was completely Japanese when I joined them. I was the first non-Japanese to join them as a regular employee in Toyota City.
我是约翰·舒克。当我加入丰田时，丰田和丰田市完全是日本化的。我是第一个以正式员工身份加入丰田市的非日本人。
John Shook moved to Japan in the early 1980s because of his fascination with Japanese management techniques. He read books about them back home in east Tennessee. And he decided to fly halfway around the globe, learn to speak the language, and hunt for a job with the biggest Japanese company that would have him. Toyota hired him to train American workers in the joint venture.
约翰·舒克因对日本管理技术的着迷而在20世纪80年代初搬到了日本。他在家乡东田纳西州读过关于这些技术的书。他决定飞越半个地球，学习说那种语言，并寻找一家愿意接纳他的最大的日本公司的工作。丰田聘请他来培训合资企业中的美国工人。
Now, here was the problem that pushed Toyota into the deal. They needed to learn how to build cars in America. For years, the Japanese had been winning away customers from Detroit-- so many that now the US Congress was threatening to restrict car imports. Toyota could avoid that by making cars in the US.
现在，推动丰田达成这笔交易的问题是：他们需要学习如何在美国制造汽车。多年来，日本人一直在从底特律手中抢走客户——人数之多，以至于当时美国国会威胁要限制汽车进口。丰田可以通过在美国生产汽车来避免这种情况。
But they wanted a partner. Here's John Shook.
但他们想要一个合作伙伴。这就是约翰·舒克。
Toyota was looking specifically for things they could learn. How can we work with American workers? How can we make sure that our management system can work in North America? And they'd been pretty happy just producing in Toyota City, doing a very good job. And the idea of actually taking their system and producing outside of Toyota City was scary to them.
丰田专门寻找他们可以学习的东西。我们该如何与美国工人合作？我们如何确保我们的管理体系能在北美运作？他们一直很乐意只在丰田市生产，并且做得非常好。而真正把他们的体系带到丰田市之外去生产的想法让他们感到害怕。
Toyota was right to be scared. Compared to Japan, where auto workers and management worked together, labor relations in America were more like war. And at the GM plant in Fremont, it felt at times like hand to hand combat.
丰田的害怕是正确的。与劳资共同协作的日本相比，美国的劳资关系更像是战争。而在弗里蒙特的通用汽车工厂，有时感觉就像是肉搏战。
A former running back from the University of Arkansas named Bruce Lee ran the western region for the United Auto Workers, and was in charge of the Fremont Union Local 1364. Now, normally, somebody like Bruce Lee is supposed to defend his union members no matter what, but even he says they were awful.
一位来自阿肯色大学的前跑卫布鲁斯·李负责全美汽车工人联合会（UAW）的西部地区，并管理着弗里蒙特分会1364。通常，像布鲁斯·李这样的人无论如何都应该维护工会成员，但他甚至说他们很糟糕。
It was considered the worst workforce in the automobile industry in the United States. And it was a reputation that was well-earned. Everything was a fight.
它被认为是美国汽车工业中最差的劳动力。这个名声是当之无愧的。每件事都是一场战斗。
They spent more time on grievances and on things like that than they did on producing cars. They had strikes all the time. It was just chaos constantly.
他们花在处理不满和类似事情上的时间比花在生产汽车上的时间还要多。他们总是罢工。简直是持续的混乱。
The Fremont, California plant for General Motors was bad by GM standards. And GM's average was bad by Toyota standards. So this is the worst among the bad, mediocre plants in GM.
通用汽车位于加利福尼亚州弗里蒙特的工厂以通用汽车的标准来看很差。而通用汽车的平均水平以丰田的标准来看又很差。所以这在通用汽车平庸的工厂中也是最差的。
Again, that's Jeffrey Liker, who has interviewed workers and management at Fremont for his research.
再次说明，那是杰弗里·莱克，他在研究中采访过弗里蒙特的工人和管理层。
One of the expressions was, you can buy anything you want in the GM plant in Fremont. If you want sex, if you want drugs, if you want alcohol, it's there. During breaks, during lunchtime, if you want to gamble illegally-- any illegal activity was available for the asking within that plant.
其中一种说法是，在弗里蒙特的通用汽车工厂，你可以买到你想要的任何东西。如果你想要性，如果你想要毒品，如果你想要酒精，那里都有。在休息时间，午餐时间，如果你想非法赌博——任何非法活动都可以在厂里随便提。
Sounds like prison.
听起来像监狱。
Actually, the analogy to prison is a good analogy, because the workers were stuck there because they could not find anything close to that level of job and pay and benefits at their level of education and skill. So they were trapped there.
事实上，监狱的类比是一个很好的类比，因为工人们被困在那里，是因为他们无法在他们的教育和技能水平下找到任何接近那种工作、报酬和福利水平的工作。所以他们被困在了那里。
And they also felt like we have a job for life, and the union will always protect us. So we're stuck here, and it's long term. And then all these illegal things crop up, so we can entertain ourselves while we're stuck here.
而且他们也觉得我们有一份终身工作，工会总是会保护我们。所以我们被困在这里，而且是长期的。然后所有这些非法的事情就冒了出来，这样我们在困在这里的时候就可以娱乐自己了。
A lot of booze on the line. I mean, it was just amazing. And as  long as you did your job, they really didn't care.
流水线上有很多酒。我的意思是，这简直令人震惊。只要你完成了你的工作，他们真的不在乎。
What kind of booze? What were people drinking?
什么酒？人们在喝什么？
Whiskey, gin.
威士忌，杜松子酒。
That's Rick Madrid. He began working at the plant in 1955. He mounted tires on Chevy trucks.
那是里克·马德里。他从1955年开始在该工厂工作。他在雪佛兰卡车上安装轮胎。
When I was mounting tires, we'd drink. I'd bring a thermos of screwdrivers with me. But I never was into drugs.
当我在安装轮胎时，我们会喝酒。我会随身带一个装满螺丝刀鸡尾酒的保温杯。但我从不碰毒品。
Sex?
性？
Love it.
喜欢。
Did you ever have sex at the plant?
你在工厂里有过性行为吗？
Yeah.
有的。
Frequently?
频繁吗？
I wasn't that fortunate.
我没那么幸运。
There was a guy in here, he would be selling pot.
这里有个家伙，他会卖大麻。
Peter Ross repaired machinery on the assembly line at GM.
彼得·罗斯在通用汽车的装配线上修理机械。
I'd be walking through the plant with my tools and my radio, and you see a big cloud of smoke. You don't want to inhale it. You'd get a contact high.
我带着工具和收音机走过工厂，你会看到一大团烟雾。你不想吸入它。你会产生接触性快感。
If you're wondering how people kept their jobs, well, back then, the UAW was still quite powerful. Under the union contract, it was almost impossible to fire anybody. And if management ticked off the union, workers could just shut the plant down in minutes.
如果你好奇人们是怎么保住工作的，嗯，那时，UAW仍然相当强大。根据工会合同，几乎不可能解雇任何人。如果管理层激怒了工会，工人们可以在几分钟内让工厂停产。
With that sort of leverage, absenteeism became absurd. On a normal day, one out of five workers just didn't show up. It was even worse on Mondays. Billy Haggerty worked in hood and fender assembly. He says so few workers showed up some mornings, management couldn't start the line.
有了这种杠杆作用，旷工现象变得荒唐可笑。在正常的一天，五分之一的工人就是不来上班。周一的情况甚至更糟。比利·哈格蒂在引擎盖和挡泥板装配线上工作。他说有些早晨来的工人太少，管理层甚至无法启动流水线。
They brought a lot of people off the street to fill in when they didn't have enough people.
当他们没有足够的人手时，他们从街上找了很多人来填补。
Who would they find?
他们从哪找人？
Go right across the street to the bar and grab people out of there and bring them in.
直接穿过马路去酒吧，把里面的人抓出来带进来。
Workers filed grievances, formal complaints against management, over all kinds of things. Someone who isn't your boss asks you to clean something up? Hit them with a grievance. A manager steps in to do a job that isn't his? Grievance.
工人们对各种事情都提出了不满，即针对管理层的正式投诉。不是你老板的人让你清理某样东西？给他们一个申诉。经理介入做本不属于他的工作？申诉。
The strategy was simple. Pile up grievances, real or imagined, by the thousands, then use them to squeeze money or concessions out of management. And Fremont workers struck back at their bosses in other ways. They'd intentionally screw up the vehicles, put Coke bottles or loose bolts inside the door panels so they'd rattle and annoy the customer. They'd scratch cars.
策略很简单。成千上万地堆积不满，无论是真实的还是想象的，然后利用它们从管理层那里挤出金钱或让步。弗里蒙特的工人们还以其他方式反击老板。他们会故意弄坏车辆，把可乐瓶或松动的螺栓塞进门板里，这样它们就会发出嘎嘎声，让顾客烦恼。他们会刮伤汽车。
Richard Aguilar inspected vehicles at the plant. He saw one guy do something even worse.
理查德·阿吉拉尔在工厂检查车辆。他看到一个人做了更糟糕的事情。
He left some loose bolts on this front suspension. That was dangerous. I went and told the assistant manager right away. They went out there, and they checked it, and there were like 400 cars he'd done that too. He was mad because they had suspended him for drinking.
他在前悬架上留下了一些松动的螺栓。那是很危险的。我马上去告诉了助理经理。他们走过去检查了，他有400辆车都做了这样的手脚。他很生气，因为他们因为他喝酒而停了他的职。
By 1982, GM had had enough, and put the Fremont factory out of its misery. The company laid off thousands of workers and closed the plant.
到了1982年，通用汽车受够了，结束了弗里蒙特工厂的苦难。公司解雇了数千名工人并关闭了工厂。
The next year, when GM and Toyota began planning to reopen the plant for the joint venture, there was one thing neither company wanted to do-- hire the same union leaders who'd battled management and overseen GM's worst workforce. Then the UAW's Bruce Lee sat down with Chairman Eiji Toyoda.
第二年，当通用和丰田计划重新开放该工厂进行合资时，有一件事双方都不想做——雇用那些曾经与管理层交战并监督通用汽车最差劳动力的工会领导。然后，UAW的布鲁斯·李与丰田英二主席坐了下来。
And one of the first things I said is, I've got to hire the first 50 people.
我说的第一件事就是，我必须雇用前50名员工。
So who did you hire?
那你雇了谁？
The same leadership that was in the union before.
以前工会里的同一批领导。
Why? I thought you would try to get rid of them.
为什么？我还以为你会试图摆脱他们。
No, no, because I believed that it was the system that made it bad, not the people.
不，不，因为我相信是体制让它变坏的，而不是人。
GM was against it, but incredibly, Toyota agreed. Toyota execs believed their system would turn bad workers into good ones. Then Lee had to sell the plan to the rank and file. He held a meeting and told union members that Fremont would now be a Japanese style plant. Old seniority rules wouldn't apply. Life at the plant would be totally different. The workers hated all this.
通用汽车反对这样做，但令人难以置信的是，丰田同意了。丰田高管相信他们的体系会将坏工人变成好工人。然后李必须把这个计划推销给普通成员。他召开了一次会议，告诉工会成员，弗里蒙特现在将成为一家日本风格的工厂。旧的资历规则将不再适用。工厂的生活将完全不同。工人们讨厌这一切。
They didn't want anything changed. They wanted the plant to open exactly how it was when General Motors had it.
他们不想改变任何事情。他们希望工厂像通用汽车拥有时那样开放。
Bad cars and all?
包括制造劣质车在内？
That's what they wanted.
他们想要的就是那个。
They even hung Lee in effigy. But Lee had something very powerful on his side. Most of the workers desperately needed jobs. And Lee had them.
他们甚至吊起了李的模拟人偶。但李的一方拥有非常强大的筹码。大多数工人迫切需要工作。而李掌握着工作。
When NUMMI opened, over 85% of the workforce were old hands from GM Fremont. But to prepare them for that moment, in the spring of 1984, Toyota started flying them to Japan in groups of 30 to begin learning the Toyota system for making cars.
当NUMMI开业时，超过85%的劳动力是来自通用弗里蒙特的老手。但在1984年春天，为了让他们为那一刻做好准备，丰田开始分批次把他们送往日本，每批30人，开始学习丰田的造车系统。
Well, when the NUMMI workers first came to Japan, me, as well as certainly my Japanese bosses, had heard all these horrible things about the American worker, about the American union.
嗯，当NUMMI工人们第一次来到日本时，我和我的日本老板们一样，都听说了关于美国工人、关于美国工会的所有可怕的事情。
As the one American working in Toyota City, John Shook helped design this training.
作为在丰田市工作的唯一美国人，约翰·舒克参与设计了这次培训。
And we had certainly heard all these stories about the workforce there at the Fremont plant, and it was our job to show them a new and very different way of working. What would they do? How would they respond to this? How would they react?
我们当然听说过所有关于弗里蒙特工厂工人的故事，我们的工作是向他们展示一种全新且非常不同的工作方式。他们会做什么？他们会对这个做出什么反应？他们会有什么反应？
And no one knew. I didn't know. So everyone was very, very nervous.
没人知道。我不知道。所以每个人都非常、非常紧张。
I was kind of apprehensive about what I was going to see when I arrived in Japan.
我到日本时，对自己将看到什么感到有些忐忑。
On one of those planes was Earl Ferguson. He'd been working for GM since 1964.
其中一架飞机上坐着厄尔·弗格森。他从1964年就开始为通用汽车工作。
What were you apprehensive about?
你忐忑什么？
Whether they were going to accept us or not, you know? How they were going to react when the Americans landed in Tokyo. Everything was so new to us, you know? This was just a totally new experience.
他们是否会接受我们，你知道吗？当美国人降落在东京时，他们会做出什么反应？一切对我们来说都是那么新鲜，你知道吗？这完全是一次全新的体验。
So I will never forget.
所以我永远不会忘记。
Again, John Shook.
又是约翰·舒克。
Taking a bus, a large bus, with my small group of Japanese colleagues to pick up the first group of trainees arriving from Fremont. Television cameras were there, because this was big news in Japan at that time. And as they got off the plane, we had signs welcoming them.
坐上一辆大巴，载着我的一小群日本同事去接第一批从弗里蒙特到达的实习生。电视台的摄像机在那里，因为这在当时是日本的大新闻。当他们下飞机时，我们举着欢迎他们的标语。
News media was everywhere. We were signing autographs and taking pictures with all the young kids. Totally new experience.
新闻媒体无处不在。我们正在签名并与所有年轻人合影。完全是全新的体验。
Most of them had never been out of the United States before, and none of them, certainly, had ever been to Japan.
他们大多数人之前从未离开过美国，而且当然，他们中没有一个人去过日本。
My name is Les Myers. I've worked at General Motors for 25 years. My hobbies are fishing and bowling.
我叫莱斯·迈耶斯。我在通用汽车工作了25年。我的爱好是钓鱼和保龄球。
My name is Masaaki Tsuchihashi. My hobby is softball.
我叫土桥正明。我的爱好是垒球。
The narrator in this Japanese public television program points out that the American worker is nine years older than his Toyota trainer. He also notes for his Japanese viewers that the Americans are so much larger than the Japanese, they waste a second or two more each time they get in and out of the vehicles they're building, which makes them 10% to 15% less productive than their Asian counterparts.
这个日本公共电视节目的旁白指出，美国工人的年龄比他的丰田培训师大了九岁。他还向日本观众指出，美国人比日本人高大得多，他们每次进出制造的车辆时都会多浪费一两秒钟，这使他们的生产力比亚洲同行低10%到15%。
The key to the Toyota production system was a principle so basic it sounds like an empty management slogan. Teamwork. Back home in Fremont, GM supervisors ordered around large groups of workers. At the Takaoka plant, people were divided into teams of just four or five, switched jobs every few hours to relieve the monotony, and a team leader would step in to help whenever anything went wrong. Again, Professor Jeffrey Liker and Toyota's John Shook.
丰田生产体系的关键是一个非常基本的原则，听起来像是一个空洞的管理口号。团队合作。回到弗里蒙特，通用汽车的主管们指挥着一大群工人。在丰田高冈工厂，人们被分成四五人的小组，每隔几小时交换工作以减轻单调感，每当出现问题时，团队领导就会介入提供帮助。再次请出杰弗里·莱克教授和丰田的约翰·舒克。
And they spent about two weeks, and they worked in a Toyota plant.
他们花了两周左右的时间，在丰田工厂工作。
Hooked up at the hip with a counterpart in the Corolla plant, someone who did the exact same job you'd be doing back in Fremont.
与丰田卡罗拉工厂的一位同行形影不离，那个人做的正是你回到弗里蒙特后要做的工作。
And they start to do the job, and they were pretty proud, because they were building cars back in the United States. And they wanted to show they could do it within the time allotted, and they would usually get behind, and they would struggle, and they would try to catch up. And at some point, somebody would come over and say, do you want me to help?
他们开始做这项工作，他们相当自豪，因为他们在回美国后也会制造汽车。他们想表现出他们能在规定的时间内完成工作，他们通常会落后，他们会挣扎，他们会尝试赶上。在某个时候，会有人过来问，你需要我帮忙吗？
And that was a revelation, because nobody in the GM plant would ever ask to help. They would come and yell at you because you got behind.
那是一次启示，因为通用工厂里从来没有人会主动要求帮忙。他们会过来对你大喊大叫，因为你落后了。
Really, we wanted to give them a chance to see and experience a different way of doing things. We wanted them to see the culture there, the way people worked together to solve problems.
真的，我们想给他们一个机会去观察和体验一种不同的做事方式。我们想让他们看到那里的文化，人们一起解决问题的方式。
Then, the biggest surprise was if, when they had those problems, afterwards, somebody would come up to them and say, what are your ideas for improvement so we don't have that problem again?
然后，最大的惊喜是，如果他们遇到这些问题，之后，会有人走过来问他们，为了不再出现那个问题，你有什么改进的建议吗？
So they'd make suggestions for a different kind of tool that would be better for the job, or a different place for bolts and parts to sit that would be easier to reach.
所以他们会提出建议，比如更换一种更适合这项工作的工具，或者把螺栓和零件放在一个更容易拿到的不同位置。
They couldn't believe that responsiveness. I can't remember any time in my working life where anybody asked for my ideas to solve the problem. And they literally want to know. And when I tell them, they listen, and then suddenly they disappear, and somebody comes back with the tool that I just described. It's built, and they say try this.
他们无法相信那种响应速度。我不记得在我工作生涯中有任何时候有人询问我解决问题的想法。他们是真心想知道。当我告诉他们时，他们会倾听，然后突然他们就消失了，随后有人拿着我刚才描述的那种工具回来了。它被制造了出来，他们说试试这个。
Under the Toyota system, everyone's expected to be looking for ways to improve the production process all the time, to make the workers' job easier and more efficient, to shave extra steps and extra seconds off each worker's job. To spot defects in the cars and the causes of those defects. This is the Japanese concept of kaizen, continuous improvement. When a worker makes a suggestion that saves money, he gets a bonus of a few hundred dollars or so.
根据丰田体系，每个人都被期望一直在寻找改善生产过程的方法，让工人的工作更简单、更高效，减少每个工人工作中的多余步骤和多余秒数。还要发现汽车中的缺陷以及导致这些缺陷的原因。这就是日本人的“改善”（kaizen）理念，即持续改进。当工人提出节省开支的建议时，他会得到几百美元左右的奖金。
And if you look around the Toyota plant, you can see the result of all those improvements. Hanging shelves that travel along with the car and the worker, carrying the parts and bolts they need within easy reach. Special cushions they throw into the car frames when they have to kneel inside. Workers' tasks have been streamlined to the fewest possible steps, each step timed down to the second.
如果你环顾丰田工厂，你可以看到所有这些改进的结果。悬挂的架子随着汽车和工人移动，将他们需要的零件和螺栓放在触手可及的地方。当他们必须跪在车内时，他们会扔进车架的特殊垫子。工人的任务被精简到最少的步骤，每个步骤精确到秒。
Two seconds to pick up a bolt and put it on. Two seconds to take a gun and tighten it down.
拿起螺栓装上去需要两秒钟。拿枪拧紧它需要两秒钟。
Billy Haggerty learned the Japanese system two decades into his tenure at GM Fremont.
比利·哈格蒂在通用弗里蒙特工作了20年后才学到了日本体系。
Everything was timed out. Such and such takes such and such long to do. That's the way you did it.
一切都是定时定量的。某某事情需要多久完成。那就是你做它的方式。
At General Motors, you could be running in circles for whatever you were doing, and that's the way it is. You lose time. A car a minute don't seem like it's moving that fast, but when you don't get it, you're in the hole. There's nobody to pull you out at General Motors, so you're going to let something go.
在通用汽车，无论你在做什么，你都可能在转圈，情况就是这样。你会浪费时间。一分钟造一辆车看起来移动得并不快，但当你没有完成时，你就陷入了困境。在通用汽车没有人会拉你一把，所以你会放过一些东西。
All those mistakes added up at a GM plant, and the results were littered around the lots outside. Hundreds of misassembled cars. Cars that came off the line missing parts, cars that needed to be fixed before they could be shipped out to the dealers.
所有的那些错误在通用工厂里累积起来，结果就是外面堆满了废品。数百辆组装错误的汽车。流水线上掉下来的车缺失零件，需要修复才能运往经销商的车。
In a Toyota plant, there was nothing like this. Why did a GM plant produce so many screwed up cars? One cardinal rule that everybody in the company knew.
在丰田工厂，没有这样的事情。为什么通用工厂生产了这么多劣质车？每个人都知道的一条基本规则。
The line could never stop. Never stop the line.
流水线绝对不能停。绝不停线。
Again, Billy Haggerty, Jeffrey Liker, Rick Madrid, and Bruce Lee.
再次请出比利·哈格蒂、杰弗里·莱克、里克·马德里和布鲁斯·李。
Someone have a heart attack, kick him out of the way, keep that line running.
有人心脏病发作，把他踢开，保持流水线运转。
It was a basic sin. You're violating the Ten Commandments.
这是一种基本的罪恶。你违反了十诫。
You just don't see the line stop. I saw a guy fall in the pit, and they didn't stop the line.
你根本看不到停线。我看到一个人掉进坑里，他们都没有停线。
You saw a problem, you stopped that line, you were fired.
你看到了问题，你停止了流水线，你就被解雇了。
A long time GM manager named Ernie Schaefer explained why.
通用汽车的老经理厄尼·舍费尔解释了原因。
Because the theory was, they'll stop it all the time. They don't want to work, you know? They want to sit and play cards or whatever. That was a free break for them if the line stopped, so you wouldn't give them the ability to stop the line.
因为理论上，他们会一直停下来。他们不想工作，你知道吗？他们想坐下来打牌或者做别的。如果流水线停了，那是他们免费的休息时间，所以你不会给他们停线的权力。
John Shook, the American who helped Toyota design its training program, says this all goes back to the first assembly line created by Henry Ford.
约翰·舒克，这位帮助丰田设计培训项目的美国人，说这一切可以追溯到亨利·福特创造的第一条装配线。
What Henry Ford had basically designed was a system that he wanted the people on the floor to simply get the volume out. Get the product out the door. And someone later will worry about the quality. If we have to repair it, we'll repair it.
亨利·福特基本上设计的是一个系统，他希望现场的人员简单地把产量搞出来。把产品运出门。有人以后会担心质量问题。如果我们必须修理它，我们会修理它。
So one of the most fundamental things that Toyota did was take that and turn it on its head. So now we tell the plant floor, don't you worry about the production volume. You worry about quality. The last thing we want is to have a lot of defects flowing down the line that we have to repair later.
所以丰田所做的最基本的事情之一就是把这一点彻底颠覆。所以现在我们告诉工厂车间，别担心生产产量。你担心质量。我们最不希望看到的就是流水线上流出大量的缺陷，以至于以后必须修理。
Toyota's philosophy was quality, not quantity.
丰田的哲学是质量第一，产量第二。
In his old GM job, Billy Haggerty put on hoods and fenders and saw lots of mistakes go right down the line.
在他以前的通用汽车工作中，比利·哈格蒂安装引擎盖和挡泥板，看着大量的错误出现在流水线上。
So we had Monte Carlos with Regal front ends and vice versas, and they would just stick it on, run it out to the yard, and then change.
所以我们有装着瑞格尔（Regal）前脸的蒙特卡洛（Monte Carlo），反之亦然，他们只是装上去，开到院子里，然后再换。
And what they look like, the cars?
那些车看起来什么样？
Half Regals and half-- [LAUGHTER]. So those things would go out the door, into the yard, and be fixed out there. I did a lot of overtime in the yard, changing things back.
半个瑞格尔，半个——[笑声]。所以那些东西会开出门，进入院子，然后在那里修理。我在院子里做了很多加班，把零件换回来。
Workers told me they saw cars with engines put in backwards, cars without steering wheels or breaks. Some were so messed up they wouldn't start, and had to be towed off the line. Fixing them piled on more costs, and sometimes, taking them apart and putting them back together, workers damaged them even more.
工人们告诉我，他们看到车引擎装反了，没有方向盘或刹车的车。有些乱得连车都发动不了，必须从流水线上拖走。修理它们堆积了更多的成本，而且有时，拆开它们再装回去，工人们损坏得更厉害。
On the floor of the NUMMI plant in Fremont, Earl Ferguson showed me Toyota's solution to all this. It's a thin nylon rope that hangs on hooks along the assembly line, which became a symbol of everything that was different about the Japanese way of making cars-- the andon cord.
在弗里蒙特NUMMI工厂的车间里，厄尔·弗格森向我展示了丰田解决所有这些问题的方案。那是一根悬挂在装配线上钩子上的细尼龙绳，它成为了日本造车方式不同之处的象征——安灯（andon）绳。
These cords hanging down, that's the andon cord. That will stop the line. If he pulls the andon cord, then this light's going to come on right here. Then it'll show up on the screen that this location is down.
这些吊下来的绳子，就是安灯绳。那会停止流水线。如果他拉动安灯绳，那么这边的灯就会亮起来。然后屏幕上会显示这个位置停工了。
It also plays a surprisingly cheerful little song. Workers in each area can pick the tune. You hear it all the time in a Toyota plant.
它还会播放一首令人惊讶的轻快小曲。每个区域的工人们可以挑选曲调。你在丰田工厂里一直能听到它。
The first pull doesn't stop the line. It summons team leaders to the location. They try to correct the problem, and usually, they can do it quickly without stopping production. But if they fail, the line stops.
第一次拉动不会停线。它会召唤团队领导到该位置。他们会尝试纠正问题，通常他们可以快速做到这一点而无需停止生产。但如果他们失败了，流水线就会停止。
Then they'll correct the problem. Then they can pull the andon cord again, and the line will start.
然后他们会纠正问题。然后他们可以再次拉动安灯绳，流水线就会开始。
Now, when was the first time you ever pulled an andon cord?
那么，你第一次拉动安灯绳是什么时候？
1984.
1984年。
Where did you do it?
你在哪做的？
In Japan.
在日本。
Were you at all nervous, because you'd been taught for so many years never to stop the line?
你当时紧张吗，因为你多年来一直被教导绝不要停线？
Yeah. And it was really exciting.
是的。这真的很令人兴奋。
What got me was the fact that they had a cross bolt, and they stopped the line to repair it.
让我震惊的是，他们有一个交叉螺栓，他们停下线来修复它。
That's Rick Madrid, the worker who brought a thermos full of vodka and OJ to work every day at GM. What he saw in Japan was a kind of a bolt-- a cross bolt-- that they'd put in wrong.
那是里克·马德里，那位每天在通用汽车带一保温杯伏特加和橙汁上班的工人。他在日本看到的是一种螺栓——一个交叉螺栓——他们装错了。
And they stopped the line and repaired it, which is take the bolt out, ream the hole, put the bolt back in, instead of sending it on and putting all the other junk on top of it so you have to take it off and repair it. And whoever puts it back isn't skilled in putting trim back, so they're going to mess up.
他们停下线修复了它，也就是取出螺栓，铰孔，放回螺栓，而不是把它传下去并在上面装上所有其他的垃圾，让你不得不把它拆下来修复。而且谁把它装回去并不精通重新安装装饰件，所以他们会搞砸。
That impression, I said, gee, that makes sense. Fix it now so you don't have to go through all this stuff. That's when it dawned on me that we can do it. One bolt. One bolt changed my attitude.
那个印象，我说，天哪，这有道理。现在修好它，这样你就不用经历所有这些了。就在那时我意识到我们可以做到。一个螺栓。一个螺栓改变了我的态度。
I think that there was a combination of feelings. One feeling was, wow, this is different.
我想那是一种复杂的感情。一种感觉是，哇，这真是与众不同。
Again, that's industrial engineering professor Jeffrey Liker.
再次请出工业工程教授杰弗里·莱克。
Another feeling was of embarrassment. We've been in this industry for how many years? My whole adult life.
另一种感觉是尴尬。我们在这一行干了多少年了？我的整个成年生活。
We're Americans. We're supposed to be the best, most important country in the world, and we can't build a quality car. And these Japanese are doing it. And there was a sense of hurt pride.
我们是美国人。我们应该是世界上最棒、最重要的国家，但我们造不出高质量的汽车。而这些日本人却做到了。有一种受伤的自尊感。
Well, it was kind of-- you become a little bit ashamed, because why couldn't we do that?
嗯，这有点——你变得有点羞愧，因为为什么我们不能那样做？
Again, Earl Ferguson.
再次请出厄尔·弗格森。
You know, I think most of it was pride after that. We wanted to be able to compete with what I saw in Japan. I said, I know we can do what they can do.
你知道，我想之后大部分是自豪。我们想能够与我在日本看到的东西竞争。我说，我知道我们可以做他们能做的事。
Only two weeks later, when that first group left to go back to Fremont--
仅两周后，当第一批人员离开回弗里蒙特时——
Toyota trainer, John Shook.
丰田培训师，约翰·舒克。
We had a party, of course. A sushi party. And this was years ago, before sushi was as it is now. It was a rare thing, of course.
当然，我们举办了一个派对。一个寿司派对。那是多年前的事了，在寿司像现在这样普及之前。当然，那是一件稀罕事。
And people were crying on both sides. You had union workers, grizzled old folks that had worked on the plant floor for 30 years, and they were hugging their Japanese counterparts, just absolutely in tears.
人们双方都在哭。你有工会工人，在工厂干了30年的老手，他们拥抱他们的日本同行，泪流满面。
There's actually footage of this, though we don't know if it's the first group of Americans. The US workers are in kimonos with the Toyota name on them, and they hand their neck ties to the Japanese and hug. One man is crying.
实际上有这段录像，尽管我们不知道是不是第一批美国人。美国工人们穿着印有丰田名字的和服，他们把领带递给日本人并拥抱。一个人在哭。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
One of the Americans says, in Japanese, "Thanks to you all, we now feel confident for our success." John Shook.
其中一个美国人用日语说：“多亏了大家，我们现在对成功充满信心。”约翰·舒克。
And it might sound flowery to say 25 years later, but they had such a powerful, emotional experience of learning a new way of working-- a way that people could actually work together collaboratively as a team. We knew it wasn't going to be easy. There were a lot of hurdles to overcome. But there was no question in anyone's mind that this was going to work.
25年后再说这话听起来可能很华丽，但他们学习一种新的工作方式有一种非常强烈的、情感上的体验——一种人们实际上可以作为团队共同协作的工作方式。我们知道这不会容易。有很多障碍要克服。但没有人怀疑这会成功。
But if it was going to work, it would mean a radically different relationship between workers and management-- one where the managers trusted the workers to let them pull the andon cord and stop the line. One where the workers trusted their bosses enough to ask for help when there were problems.
但如果它要成功，就意味着工人和管理层之间完全不同的关系——经理信任工人，让他们拉动安灯绳停下线；工人信任老板，当有问题时主动请求帮助。
With teamwork, we can do it all. Now let's hold up your hands and together, with teamwork, we can do it all!
通过团队合作，我们可以做到这一切。现在让我们举起双手，一起，通过团队合作，我们可以做到这一切！
December 1984, the first car rolled off the assembly line in Fremont-- a yellow Chevy Nova. UAW rep Joel Smith was one of the speakers.
1984年12月，第一辆车从弗里蒙特的装配线上下来——一辆黄色雪佛兰Nova。UAW代表乔尔·史密斯是发言人之一。
Mr. Toyoda, staff, and fellow UAW members, today is a historic one. The first car. But we're also on the threshold of a new adventure and relationship between labor and management.
丰田先生、职员们，以及工会成员同事们，今天是历史性的一天。第一辆车。但我们也正处在劳资之间新冒险和新关系的门槛上。
For too long, the American worker has been maligned, criticized, called bad names, for building lousy products, poor quality American worker. At New United Motor, we will build a quality car, and we will only build a quality car. And Mr. Toyoda, if you would please deliver this challenge to our friends in Japan-- we intend to build the best quality car in the world. Thank you.
长期以来，美国工人一直受到诽谤、批评、叫难听的名字，因为制造了糟糕的产品，劣质的美国工人。在新联合汽车，我们将制造高质量的汽车，我们只会制造高质量的汽车。丰田先生，如果您能把这个挑战传达给我们日本的朋友——我们打算制造世界上质量最好的汽车。谢谢。
They hit the ground running. It didn't take a year, two years to get quality in that product.
他们起步非常快。产品获得高质量并不需要一年、两年。
Again, the UAW's Bruce Lee.
再次请出UAW的布鲁斯·李。
Oh, I was so proud of them, you can't believe. The fact that they did it didn't surprise me that much, but how quickly they did it did. It was amazing.
噢，我为他们感到自豪，你无法相信。事实上他们做到了并没有让我那么吃惊，但他们做到的速度确实让我吃惊。真是太棒了。
Here were these same people who before, I mean, were-- hell, they'd go out of their way to make life miserable for General Motors particularly. And, you know, they were old, they were fat, because that was not a young workforce that we brought in here.
这就是那群人，在此之前，我的意思是，他们——见鬼，他们会不遗余力地让通用汽车特别痛苦。而且，你知道，他们老了，他们胖了，因为我们带到这里的不是一支年轻的劳动力队伍。
The numbers coming out of the NUMMI plant were astonishing. Again, here's Jeffrey Liker.
从NUMMI工厂出来的数字令人震惊。再次请出杰弗里·莱克。
The best measure they use is how many defects are there per 100 vehicles. And it was one of the best in America. And it was the same for the Toyota cars that were made in California as the Corollas that were coming from Japan, right from the beginning.
他们使用的最佳衡量标准是每100辆车有多少缺陷。它是美国最好的工厂之一。从一开始，加州制造的丰田汽车和从日本运来的卡罗拉在质量上是一样的。
Maryann Keller, a long time car analyst, devotes a chapter to NUMMI in her book about the rise and fall of GM, Rude Awakening . After just three months, she says, the cars coming off the line were getting near perfect quality ratings. And just as important for GM were the cost savings.
玛丽安·凯勒，一位资深的汽车分析师，在她关于通用汽车兴衰的书《粗鲁的觉醒》中专门用了一章来写NUMMI。她说，仅仅三个月后，流水线上下来的汽车就获得了接近完美的质量评级。对通用汽车同样重要的是成本节约。
One study suggested, remarkably, it would probably take 50% more workers under the old system to build the same car. Grievances and absenteeism plummeted, and lots of workers preferred the NUMMI teamwork system to the old combative one at GM. Several told us they enjoyed coming to work for the first time.
一项研究非凡地指出，在旧体制下，制造同一辆车可能需要多50%的工人。不满和旷工现象暴跌，许多工人更喜欢NUMMI的团队合作制度，而不是通用汽车旧的对抗制度。几个人告诉我们，这是他们第一次喜欢来上班。
I didn't want to tell people I worked at the Chevy truck plant, because a lot of people had a lot of problems with them.
我不想告诉别人我在雪佛兰卡车工厂工作，因为很多人对它们有意见。
That's Rick Madrid, who spent 17 years at the old Fremont plant building Chevy trucks. He was ashamed of that vehicle. At NUMMI, making the Nova, he felt differently.
那是里克·马德里，他在旧弗里蒙特工厂制造雪佛兰卡车工作了17年。他为那种车感到羞耻。在NUMMI，制造Nova时，他的感觉不同了。
Oh, I had a stack of these postcards. And I would just drive around. If I'd see a Nova parked, I would put one of these under the windshield wiper. Of course, it had my name, my address on it, and your opinion of the Nova? And just basically, they'd drop me a line, and a lot of people did this.
噢，我有一叠这些明信片。我会开车到处转。如果我看到停着的Nova，我会把一张放在挡风玻璃雨刷下。当然，上面有我的名字、地址，你对Nova的评价是什么？基本上，他们会给我写信，很多人都这么做了。
And what did they say?
他们说了什么？
Some said they really liked it-- a quality car. A good car.
有些人说他们真的很喜欢——一款高质量的车。一辆好车。
Another worker told me he'd go to the Chevy dealership to stare at the Novas. He didn't tell anyone he built them, or that he worked at NUMMI. He just liked seeing what the cars looked like, sitting there on the lot.
另一位工人告诉我，他会去雪佛兰经销商处盯着Nova看。他没有告诉任何人他制造了它们，或者他在NUMMI工作。他只是喜欢看车停在场上的样子。
That's NPR's Frank Langfitt. Coming up, so there's this great way of making cars. GM is using it in California, and not only are the cars more reliable, they're cheaper to make. Seems like a no brainer for GM. Start putting this way of producing cars into their other factories everywhere, and declare victory.
那是NPR的弗兰克·朗菲特。接下来，有这么一种制造汽车的好方法。通用汽车在加州使用它，不仅汽车更可靠，制造起来也更便宜。对通用汽车来说这似乎是个不需要动脑筋的选择。开始在他们到处的所有其他工厂引入这种生产汽车的方法，并宣布胜利。
Why they didn't do that, why what happened at NUMMI stayed at NUMMI for so long-- that's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
为什么他们没有那样做，为什么NUMMI发生的事情在NUMMI保持了那么久——稍后揭晓，来自芝加哥公共广播电台，节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. If you're just tuning in, we're in the middle of a story about a car plant in Fremont, California called NUMMI. We now turn to the question, why was it so hard for GM to replicate NUMMI elsewhere in the company? Why didn't this idea spread decades ago?
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。如果你刚收听，我们正在讲述一个位于加利福尼亚州弗里蒙特名为NUMMI的汽车工厂的故事。我们现在转向一个问题，为什么通用汽车在公司其他地方复制NUMMI如此困难？为什么这个想法没有在几十年前传播开来？
In the first half of our story, we heard a lot from workers who were on the factory floor. In this half of the story, the action moves to their bosses-- the supervisors at GM-- who had a chance to turn the company around with what they learned at NUMMI. Again, here's NPR's Frank Langfitt.
在我们故事的前半部分，我们听到了许多工厂车间工人的心声。在故事的这一半，行动转向了他们的老板——通用汽车的主管们——他们本有机会通过在NUMMI学到的东西来扭转公司局面。再次请出NPR的弗兰克·朗菲特。
GM had gotten the first thing it wanted out of NUMMI-- a high quality small car. Now the question was, how could it spread the lessons of NUMMI throughout the rest of the company? To do that, it set up a special liaison office. Managers were flown in for tours and to work the assembly line for a few days to learn the team concept.
通用汽车已经从NUMMI获得了它想要的第一样东西——一款高质量的小型车。现在的问题是，它如何将NUMMI的经验传播到公司其余部分？为了做到这一点，它成立了一个特别的联络办公室。经理们被飞往这里进行参观，并在流水线上工作几天来学习团队概念。
And from the beginning, GM executives sent 16 of their rising stars to help start NUMMI, with the idea that later, they'd come home and change the company. Two Wall Street Journal reporters later dubbed them the NUMMI commandos. One of the 16 was Mark Hogan. He says the top brass understood NUMMI's game changing potential, that a Toyota style plant squeezed many more cars out of far fewer workers.
从一开始，通用汽车高管就派出了16位冉冉升起的新星来帮助启动NUMMI，想法是以后他们会回家改变公司。《华尔街日报》的两位记者后来称他们为“NUMMI突击队”。其中之一是马克·霍根。他说高层领导理解NUMMI改变游戏规则的潜力，即丰田风格的工厂从更少的工人手中压榨出更多的汽车。
If General Motors was able to take its many manufacturing facilities and implement that production system, it meant billions to General Motors in the bottom line.
如果通用汽车能够利用其众多的制造设施并实施该生产体系，这对通用汽车的净利润意味着数十亿美元。
We were ready. We were fired, and we had the mental condition that says, we're going to do this. We're going to change the world.
我们准备好了。我们被点燃了，我们有一种心态，说，我们要做到这一点。我们要改变世界。
That's Steve Bera, another commando. He says once NUMMI was up and running, he and the other 15 waited to be deployed elsewhere for the next phase of their mission. But the company didn't seem to know what to do with them.
那是史蒂夫·贝拉，另一位突击队员。他说一旦NUMMI运转起来，他和另外15个人就等待着被部署到其他地方去执行下一阶段的任务。但公司似乎不知道该拿他们怎么办。
Instead of coming back to the 16 of us and saying, there's some secret sauce here. What is it? How can we use this to our advantage? No one ever asked us that question.
没有人回到我们这16个人中间问，这里有什么秘诀吗？它是什么？我们如何利用它来为我们谋利？从来没有人问过我们那个问题。
Why didn't they do that?
为什么他们没有那样做？
It was never part of a master plan. And if there was a master plan, none of us ever saw it.
它从来不是总计划的一部分。如果有总计划，我们谁也没见过。
Frustrated, Bera quit after just two years at NUMMI. With no master plan from Detroit, the first real attempt to do NUMMI again came from a factory manager, 400 miles south of Fremont, at a plant in Van Nuys. The factory was facing a possible shutdown. Its manager, a guy named Ernie Schaefer, had visited NUMMI, and he thought maybe he could save his plant if he adopted the Japanese system.
感到沮丧的贝拉在NUMMI工作仅两年后就辞职了。由于底特律没有总计划，再次尝试NUMMI的第一次真正尝试来自一位工厂经理，距离弗里蒙特以南400英里的范奈斯（Van Nuys）工厂。该工厂面临可能关闭。它的经理，一个叫厄尼·舍费尔的人，参观过NUMMI，他想如果他采用日本体系，也许能拯救他的工厂。
But he didn't have all the advantages Fremont had. This time, Toyota wasn't a partner in the experiment. GM had to transform Van Nuys on its own. Ernie Schaefer knew it was going to be tough.
但他没有弗里蒙特那样的所有优势。这一次，丰田不是实验的合作伙伴。通用汽车必须独自转型范奈斯。厄尼·舍费尔知道这会很艰难。
The thing that I think kept us moving forward is we had no alternative. I mean, it was pretty well known that if we didn't successfully implement this philosophy in Van Nuys, we weren't going to be around.
我认为让我们继续前进的是我们别无选择。我的意思是，众所周知，如果我们不在范奈斯成功实施这一哲学，我们就不会存在了。
Van Nuys made Firebirds and Camaros, and its reputation wasn't much better than GM Fremont's had been-- defective cars coming off the line, battles with the union, sabotage. So Ernie Schaefer enlisted the same UAW leader who got the union on board at NUMMI, Bruce Lee, to help him win over the Van Nuys workforce. They shut down the plant for two weeks to train everyone in team concept and quality control.
范奈斯制造火鸟（Firebird）和卡玛洛（Camaro），它的声誉并不比当年的通用弗里蒙特好多少——流水线上有缺陷的汽车、与工会的争斗、破坏活动。所以厄尼·舍费尔请来了在NUMMI让工会参与的同一位UAW领导人布鲁斯·李，帮助他赢得范奈斯工人的支持。他们关闭工厂两周，培训每个人的团队概念和质量控制。
For this workforce, there were no trips to Japan, no tearful sushi parties. And from the start, workers were skeptical.
对于这些工人，没有去日本的旅行，没有泪流满面的寿司派对。从一开始，工人们就持怀疑态度。
The lack of receptiveness to change was so deep.
对改变的接受能力极其低下。
Larry Spiegel was another NUMMI commando. He moved down to Van Nuys to help launch the Japanese system there.
拉里·斯皮格尔是另一位NUMMI突击队员。他搬到范奈斯帮助启动那里的日本体系。
There were too many people convinced that they didn't need to have to change.
有太多人确信他们不需要改变。
Hadn't General Motors threatened to close the plant?
通用汽车不是威胁要关闭工厂吗？
They didn't believe them.
他们不相信他们。
Why?
为什么？
It's not logical. They just didn't.
这不合逻辑。他们就是不信。
This was one of the biggest differences between Fremont and Van Nuys. Van Nuys hadn't been shut down. Turns out it's a lot easier to get workers to change if they've lost their jobs, and then you offer them back. Without that, many union members just saw the Toyota system as a threat.
这是弗里蒙特和范奈斯之间最大的区别之一。范奈斯没有被关闭过。事实证明，如果工人们失去了工作，然后你让他们回来，让他们改变要容易得多。没有那个，许多工会成员只是把丰田体系看作一种威胁。
And they had a point. Under the Japanese system, Van Nuys stood to lose a fourth of its workforce, because the more efficient a plant becomes, the fewer workers it needs. And just as bad, the team concept hurt their seniority rights. This had been a problem for union members back at NUMMI also.
而且他们有道理。在日系体系下，范奈斯可能失去四分之一的劳动力，因为工厂变得越高效，需要的工人就越少。同样糟糕的是，团队概念损害了他们的资历权利。这也是NUMMI工会成员曾经遇到的问题。
Your seniority is what you work for. To me, that's what a union's about. Seniority.
你的资历是你努力工作争取来的。对我来说，这就是工会的意义所在。资历。
Richard Aguilar worked at NUMMI, and to him, seniority was just another way of saying fairness. He waited 15 years to get enough seniority for the job he'd always wanted in the plant. Under the new system, management could just hire someone off the street for that job. The whole idea of seniority placing you into one great job for years was impossible under the team concept. Workers had to learn every job on their team and take turns doing those jobs.
理查德·阿吉拉尔在NUMMI工作，对他来说，资历只是公平的另一种说法。他等了15年才获得足够的资历得到他在工厂里一直想要的工作。在新体系下，管理层可以直接在街上雇用某人来做那份工作。团队概念下，整个资历为你安排一个好工作的想法是不可能的。工人们必须学习团队中的每一项工作，并轮流做这些工作。
And the team concept, it sounds good. I mean, team player sounds good, but it pit worker against worker. It really does.
团队概念听起来不错。我的意思是，团队球员听起来不错，但它让工人和工人对立。确实如此。
This was the other thing Richard hated about the Japanese system. The whole point of a union, its most basic principle, was to protect you from management. But once people were working in teams, Richard says union members started doing things for management that just seemed wrong.
这是理查德讨厌日本体系的另一件事。工会的全部意义，其最基本的原则，是保护你免受管理层侵害。但一旦人们在团队中工作，理查德说工会成员开始为管理层做一些看起来不对的事情。
People now snitched on each other. You know, they'd point fingers. Oh, he's not doing this job right, you know, or she's not doing the job right. And they would even keep track of stuff they'd missed, because that's what the company puts on them-- that the only way you can protect your job, you have to keep the team strong. So there's a weak link, you've got to get rid of that weak link.
人们现在互相告密。你知道，他们会指指点点。哦，他这项工作没做好，你知道，或者她没做好工作。他们甚至会记录下他们错过的东西，因为那是公司施加给他们的——保护你工作的唯一方法，就是保持团队强大。所以如果有一个薄弱环节，你就必须摆脱那个薄弱环节。
And I would go tell them, you can't do that. You can't build a case for management against a union member. It made me angry and disappointed that the union had gotten so backwards that they'd forgotten what a union meant-- taking care of each other.
我会跑去告诉他们，你们不能那样做。你们不能为管理层建立针对工会成员的案件。工会变得如此落后，以至于他们忘记了工会的意义——互相照顾，这让我感到愤怒和失望。
At Van Nuys, it wasn't just union members who resisted the Japanese system. Managers were against it too. Like the union members, they didn't want change. There were things they liked about the old system. It gave them privileges and perks they'd now be losing.
在范奈斯，不仅仅是工会成员抵制日本体系。经理们也反对它。像工会成员一样，他们不想改变。他们喜欢旧体系中的一些东西。它赋予了他们现在将失去的特权和好处。
For instance, some managers opposed the idea of stopping the assembly line, because their bonuses depended on the number of cars that rolled off the line. Never mind how many defects they had. And now that workers and managers were supposed to be a team, executives and workers would share the same cafeteria and same parking lot, as equals. Managers at NUMMI didn't have a problem with that, but the managers at Van Nuys?
例如，一些经理反对停流水线的想法，因为他们的奖金取决于流水线上走下来的汽车数量。别管他们有多少缺陷。既然工人和经理现在应该是一个团队，高管和工人们将在同一个食堂、同一个停车场平等共处。NUMMI的经理们没问题，但范奈斯的经理们呢？
They rioted.
他们闹翻了。
The UAW's Bruce Lee remembers getting a phone call from plant supervisor Ernie Schaefer about his managers.
UAW的布鲁斯·李记得接到了工厂主管厄尼·舍费尔关于他经理们的电话。
They basically told Ernie, you do that and we're out of here. We're going to quit en masse. Because Ernie called me, and he said, Bruce, I can't do it. I can't do those things.
他们基本上告诉厄尼，你那样做我们就走人。我们要集体辞职。因为厄尼给我打了电话，他说，布鲁斯，我做不到。我做不到那些事。
I said, just think about it. That's a nothing. So they have to walk 20 yards more. I said, isn't that foolish that some grown man would come up and tell you, I'm going to quit if I can't have this parking place right here?
我说，想想看。那没什么。他们只需要多走20码。我说，一个成年人跑来告诉你，如果我不能有这个停车位我就辞职，这不是太愚蠢了吗？
So people fought the new system from both sides. Managers gave Ernie grief, and a dissident faction sprang up in the local union, which elected a staunch opponent of the Japanese system as their chairman. And as if that all wasn't enough, Ernie Schaefer ran into another obstacle. Workers could only build cars as good as the parts they were given. At NUMMI, many of the parts came from Japan and were really good. At Van Nuys, it was totally different.
所以人们从两方面抵制新体系。经理们给厄尼带来痛苦，当地工会中出现了一个持不同政见的派系，选举了一位日本体系的坚定反对者作为主席。而且如果这还不够，厄尼·舍费尔还遇到了另一个障碍。工人只能制造出和他们得到的零件一样好的汽车。在NUMMI，许多零件来自日本，非常好。在范奈斯，完全不同。
That was perhaps one of our biggest failures in that an isolated plant can't do this by itself.
这也许是我们最大的失败之一，因为一个孤立的工厂不能独自完成这件事。
The team concept stressed continuous improvement. If a team got a shipment of parts that didn't fit, they'd alert their bosses, who'd then go to the suppliers to fix the problem. Sometimes they'd realize the problem was in the part's design, and Toyota engineers would go back to the drawing board and remake the part to address the problem workers were having on the assembly line. All the departments in the company worked together.
团队概念强调持续改进。如果一个团队收到了不匹配的零件，他们会提醒老板，老板随后会去找供应商解决问题。有时他们会意识到问题出在零件的设计上，丰田工程师会回到绘图板上重新设计零件，以解决工人在装配线上遇到的问题。公司里的所有部门都一起工作。
But Ernie's suppliers had never operated in a system like that. If he asked for fixes, they blew him off. And if he called Detroit and asked them to redesign a part that wasn't working, they'd ask him, why was he so special? They didn't have to change it for any other plant. Why should they change it for him?
但厄尼的供应商从来没有在这样的体系下运作过。如果他要求修复，他们就把他打发了。如果他给底特律打电话要求重新设计一个不工作的零件，他们会问他，为什么他那么特别？他们不需要为任何其他工厂改变它。为什么要为他改变？
You had asked the question earlier, what's different when you walk into the NUMMI plant? Well, you can see a lot of things different. But the one thing you don't see is the system that supports the NUMMI plant. I don't think at that time, anybody understood the large nature of this system.
你之前问过这个问题，当你走进NUMMI工厂时有什么不同？嗯，你可以看到很多不同之处。但你没有看到的是支持NUMMI工厂的系统。我不认为那时有人理解这个系统的大规模本质。
General Motors was a kind of throw it over the wall organization. You know, each department-- we were very compartmentalized, and you'd design that vehicle, and you'd throw it over the wall to the manufacturing guys.
通用汽车是一种“扔过墙”的组织。你知道，每个部门——我们非常隔阂，你设计那辆车，然后把它扔过墙给制造部门。
And if something didn't work, or was impossible to assemble, that was their problem.
如果有什么不起作用，或者组装不可能，那是他们的问题。
And they had to deal with it. And, I mean, you're in there. You've kind of put your heart and soul into making this whole team concept work. And now you're the messenger that has to go out and say, look, guys, even though this is the way the system's supposed to work, and these are my issues, I'm not going to be able to solve them, and you're going to have to deal with it.
他们必须处理它。而且，我的意思是，你在那里。你把心和灵魂投入到让整个团队概念工作。现在你是传达这个消息的人，必须说，看，伙计们，即使这是系统应该工作的方式，这些是我的问题，我无法解决它们，你们必须处理它们。
And it was destructive. It was detrimental. I mean, no question about it.
这是破坏性的。这是有害的。我的意思是，毫无疑问。
Schaefer says when he realized how much of the Japanese system happened off the factory floor, it answered something that had never quite made sense to him. Why had Toyota been so open with GM in showing its operations?
舍费尔说，当他意识到日本体系中有多少是在工厂车间之外发生的时候，它回答了他从未完全想通的事情。为什么丰田在展示其运营时对通用如此开放？
You know, they never prohibited us from walking through the plant, understanding, even asking questions of some of their key people. You know, I've often puzzled over that-- why they did that. And I think they recognized we were asking all the wrong questions.
你知道，他们从来没有禁止我们走过工厂，了解情况，甚至询问他们的一些关键人物。你知道，我经常为此感到困惑——为什么他们那样做。我想他们认识到我们问的所有问题都错了。
We didn't understand this bigger picture thing. All of our questions were focused on the floor, you know? The assembly plant. What's happening on the line. That's not the real issue. The issue is, how do you support that system with all the other functions that have to take place in the organization?
我们不了解这张更大的图景。我们所有的问题都集中在车间，你知道吗？装配厂。流水线上发生了什么。那不是真正的问题。问题是，你如何通过组织内必须发生的其他所有职能来支持那个系统？
Quality at Van Nuys didn't improve, and in 1992, GM shut the plant down for good, leaving 2,600 people without jobs. This is what the NUMMI commandos were up against. Entrenched, defensive bureaucracies and workers many of the places they turned. They were not only trying to change the biggest corporation in the world. They were trying to change a corporation that had been essentially a collection of individual car companies-- Cadillac, Oldsmobile, Pontiac, Buick-- each with its own design team, own leadership, and its own way of doing things.
范奈斯的质量没有提高，1992年，通用汽车彻底关闭了工厂，留下2600人失业。这就是NUMMI突击队员所面临的。根深蒂固、防御性的官僚机构和工人在他们转向的许多地方。他们不仅试图改变世界上最大的公司。他们试图改变一个本质上是个人汽车公司集合——凯迪拉克、奥兹莫比尔、庞蒂亚克、别克——每一家都有自己的设计团队、领导力和做事方式的集团。
It's a whole new process, a whole different process, than the one they had grown up with. And it was a huge threat.
这是一个全新的过程，一个与他们成长过程完全不同的过程。这是一个巨大的威胁。
Dick Fuller was another commando. He ran the information technology division at NUMMI, which used some of the same streamlining concepts employed on the factory floor. He says when GM managers visited NUMMI, instead of trying to figure out how they could benefit from the system, some of them attacked it. Fuller remembers one IT manager who visited from a plant on the East Coast.
迪克·富勒是另一位突击队员。他经营NUMMI的信息技术部门，该部门使用了一些与工厂车间相同的精简概念。他说当通用汽车经理参观NUMMI时，他们没有试图弄清楚如何从系统中受益，有些人攻击它。富勒记得一位来自东海岸工厂的IT经理。
And when he came back, he wrote a report, which, if I put a title on it, would say, won't work here. And I think part of that was a threat to him. It was a threat to him to see that it was working so well.
当他回来时，他写了一份报告，如果我给它起个标题，会写着：这里行不通。我认为部分原因是对他构成的威胁。看到它运行得如此好对他来说是一种威胁。
Do you think this guy looked at this and said, well, if this works here, and they try to spread it, I'll lose my job?
你认为这个人看着这个说，如果这在这里有效，而他们试图传播它，我会失业吗？
Well, I don't think he was going to lose his job, but he'd probably have to give up half his staff, you know? So that's power. It's people that's power in General Motors.
嗯，我不认为他会失业，但他可能不得不放弃他一半的员工，你知道吗？所以那是权力。在通用汽车中人就是权力。
Getting all these mini empires to embrace the kinds of radical changes that happened at NUMMI would have taken an almost Stalinesque leadership from above-- a combination of charisma and fury in the corner office. And NUMMI commando Mark Hogan says no one at GM fit that bill.
让所有这些迷你帝国拥抱NUMMI所发生的那种激进变革，需要来自高层的近乎斯大林式的领导——办公室角落里魅力与愤怒的结合。NUMMI突击队员马克·霍根说，通用汽车没有人符合这一要求。
I was very convinced that we had to change, and we had to change rapidly. And I think all of us that were NUMMI alums, so to speak, were frustrated at the lack of urgency.
我非常确信我们必须改变，我们必须迅速改变。我认为我们所有作为NUMMI校友的人，都可以说，对缺乏紧迫感感到沮丧。
Did you have those kinds of conversations with people in the '80s back in Detroit?
你在80年代在底特律和人们进行过那样的谈话吗？
I did.
我有。
What would people say to you?
人们会对你说什么？
Yeah. I think there still wasn't a recognition that the formidability of the competition, particularly from Toyota-- I think a lot of people were in denial, or just not willing to recognize it. And even though GM had gone from 50% market share in the early '70s to mid-30s, it was gradual over time, and there wasn't the sense of reaction or urgency that other companies that lost that much market share might have felt.
是的。我认为仍然没有认识到竞争的强大，特别是来自丰田的竞争——我认为许多人处于否认状态，或者只是不愿意承认它。尽管通用汽车的市场份额从70年代初的50%降至30年代中期，但这是随着时间的推移逐渐发生的，并没有其他公司失去那么多市场份额时可能感受到的那种反应或紧迫感。
Those exact numbers? GM went from 47% of the US market in the mid-1970s to 35% a decade later. One reason car execs were in denial was Detroit's insular culture. Yes, unions and management were always at each other's throats, and yes, GM and its suppliers had a destructive relationship that seemed to almost discourage quality. But everyone had settled into comfortable roles in this dysfunctional system and learned to live with it. And in the late 1980s, with their market share in freefall, Jeffrey Liker says they were more apt to blame others than themselves.
那些确切的数字？通用汽车在美国的市场份额从1975年中期的47%降至十年后的35%。汽车高管处于否认状态的原因之一是底特律封闭的文化。是的，工会和管理层总是针锋相对，是的，通用和其供应商之间有一种破坏性的关系，似乎几乎抑制了质量。但每个人都在这种功能失调的系统中安定在舒适的角色中，并学会了生活在其中。在80年代末，随着他们的市场份额自由落体，杰弗里·莱克说他们更容易责怪别人而不是自己。
I worked with all the big three, at the time, automakers, and it was common in all three automakers. They all believed that if the consumers think we have quality problems, it's because Consumer Reports is misleading them, and they're biased toward Toyota. They all believed that Consumer Reports was against them-- that there was somewhat of a myth of Japanese quality.
当时我和所有三大汽车制造商合作过，这在所有三家制造商中都很普遍。他们都认为如果消费者认为我们有质量问题，那是因为《消费者报告》误导了他们，而且他们偏袒丰田。他们都认为《消费者报告》反对他们——某种日本质量的神话。
If all of that wasn't enough to stymie attempts to learn from NUMMI, GM was distracted by other projects-- massive projects. It bought Ross Perot's company, Electronic Data Systems. It bought Hughes Aircraft for $5 billion. It decided the future was robotics. It decided the future was a massive, costly reorganization. It started Saturn, which produced cars that were better marketed than they were built.
如果所有这些还不足以阻碍从NUMMI学习的尝试，通用汽车还被其他项目分散了注意力——巨大的项目。它收购了罗斯·佩罗（Ross Perot）的公司，电子数据系统（EDS）。它斥资50亿美元收购了休斯飞机公司（Hughes Aircraft）。它认为未来是机器人技术。它认为未来是一个大规模、昂贵的重组。它开始了土星（Saturn），它生产的汽车营销得比制造得好。
Then came the 1991 recession. Car sales slumped. Again, Mark Hogan.
然后是1991年的经济衰退。汽车销售疲软。再次请出马克·霍根。
It was really its first significant wake up call. GM, unfortunately, had a massive loss in 1992. General Motors lost more than $20 billion. So I think at that point in time, there was a complete rethinking of the way we ran the company-- that things had to change, and they had to change fast.
这真的是它第一次重大的警钟。不幸的是，通用汽车在1992年遭受了巨大的亏损。通用汽车亏损了超过200亿美元。所以我认为在那个时间点，对我们经营公司的方式进行了全面的重新思考——事情必须改变，而且必须快。
It was the largest loss in American corporate history to that time-- $23.5 billion. GM's board of directors responded with what the press called a boardroom bloodbath, purging a long list of managers. Jack Smith took over as CEO. He was the executive who led the negotiations with Toyota to create NUMMI.
那是当时美国公司历史上最大的亏损——235亿美元。通用汽车董事会以媒体所说的“董事会大屠杀”做出了回应，清洗了长长的经理名单。杰克·史密斯接任CEO。他是领导与丰田谈判创建NUMMI的高管。
He saw NUMMI as a way forward for GM. Mark Hogan and some of the other commandos felt they finally had a champion.
他看到了NUMMI是通用汽车的前进方向。马克·霍根和其他一些突击队员觉得他们终于有了一个拥护者。
Jack Smith was installed, and started to rapidly implement the Toyota production system into General Motors.
杰克·史密斯上任，并开始迅速将丰田生产体系实施到通用汽车。
Rapidly by GM standards, which wasn't nearly rapidly enough. Jack Smith declined to talk to me for this story, but he told a reporter a few years ago, "I just wish it had happened a lot faster than it did." Pick your nautical cliche. Reforming General Motors was like turning around a battleship, one manager said. Another compared it to steering the Titanic with a canoe paddle. Jeffrey Liker says the cultural gap between NUMMI and the rest of GM was so vast that even with clear marching orders to change, some of the people running the company didn't know where to begin.
以通用汽车的标准来看是迅速的，但远不够快。杰克·史密斯拒绝为这个故事接受我的采访，但他几年前告诉一位记者，“我只是希望它发生得比实际快得多。”选择你的航海陈词滥调。重组通用汽车就像掉头一艘战列舰，一位经理说。另一个人把它比作划着独木舟桨去操纵泰坦尼克号。杰弗里·莱克说，NUMMI和通用汽车其余部分之间的文化鸿沟如此巨大，以至于即使有明确的改变指令，经营公司的一些人也不知道从哪里开始。
There was no vocabulary, even, to explain it. I remember one of the GM managers was ordered from a very senior level-- it came from a vice president-- to make a GM plant look like NUMMI. And he said, I want you to go there with cameras and take a picture of every square inch. And whatever you take a picture of, I want it to look like that in our plant. There should be no excuse for why we're different than NUMMI, why our quality is lower, why our productivity isn't as high, because you're going to copy everything you see.
甚至没有词汇来解释它。我记得通用汽车的一位经理接到高级别的命令——来自一位副总裁——让一家通用工厂看起来像NUMMI。他说，我要你带着摄像机去那里，拍下每一平方英寸的照片。无论你拍下什么，我都希望我们的工厂看起来那样。对于为什么我们和NUMMI不同，为什么我们的质量更低，为什么我们的生产力没有那么高，不应该有任何借口，因为你将复制你看到的一切。
Immediately, this guy knew that was crazy. We can't copy employee motivation. We can't copy good relationships between the union and management. That's not something you can copy, and you can't even take a photograph of it.
立即，这个人知道那是疯狂的。我们无法复制员工动力。我们无法复制工会和管理层之间的良好关系。那不是你可以复制的东西，你甚至无法给它拍照。
The first round of changes put andon cords and Japanese-style inventory control into the GM plants, but there was no change in the culture. Workers and managers continued their old antagonistic ways. In some of the factories where they installed the andon cord, workers got yelled at when they pulled it. A few plants even cut the cords down.
第一轮变革将安灯绳和日本式的库存控制引入了通用工厂，但文化没有改变。工人和经理继续他们旧的对抗方式。在一些安装了安灯绳的工厂里，工人在拉动它时被大喊大叫。几家工厂甚至把绳子割断了。
So the second round of changes included some team concepts. They put together a book explaining how each plant should run and the reasoning behind it. Jeff Weller was one of the people dispatched in the 1990s to convert the company plant by plant. Weller says some factory managers were receptive, but in the sprawling, decentralized system, the plant manager was still king, and ran the factory the way he wanted.
所以第二轮变革包括了一些团队概念。他们整理了一本书，解释每家工厂应该如何运行及其背后的原因。杰夫·韦勒是90年代被派去逐个工厂改造公司的人之一。韦勒说一些工厂经理是接受的，但在蔓延、分散的体系中，工厂经理仍然是国王，并按照他想要的方式经营工厂。
We had some tough goes in some of our facilities, where we spent more time trying to convince the plant leadership versus actually going on and doing the implementation. I would say, I was asked in one plant to leave, because they were not interested in what I had to sell.
我们在一些设施中经历了一些艰难的时刻，我们花了更多时间试图说服工厂领导层，而不是实际去执行。我想说，有一次我在一家工厂被要求离开，因为他们对我所要推销的东西不感兴趣。
How did he actually ask you to leave? What did he say?
他是怎么实际要求你离开的？他说了什么？
We're finished, and you can leave.
我们完了，你可以走了。
And what did you do?
你做了什么？
I left, because, you know, I was in his home, so to speak. His territory. His plant.
我离开了，因为你知道，我是在他的家里，可以说。他的领地。他的工厂。
Now, whatever happened to that plant manager who asked you to leave?
现在，那个要求你离开的工厂经理后来怎么样了？
That plant manager eventually retired.
那个工厂经理最终退休了。
This may sound like a naive question, but why didn't the CEO pick up the phone and say, you're fired?
这听起来可能是一个天真的问题，但为什么CEO不拿起电话说，你被解雇了？
Well, it's a big company, and I'm not sure that, you know-- it doesn't work that way.
嗯，这是一家大公司，我不确定，你知道——事情不是那样运作的。
Lots of people in GM still didn't see the need to change. By the late 1990s, the company was posting huge profits selling trucks and SUVs, which made the loss in market share seem less urgent. To make real progress, managers had to leave the United States. One overhauled GM Germany.
通用汽车里的许多人仍然认为不需要改变。到90年代末，公司在销售卡车和SUV方面取得了巨大的利润，这使得市场份额的流失看起来不那么紧迫。为了取得真正的进步，经理们不得不离开美国。一个人整顿了通用汽车德国。
Mark Hogan took over GM Brazil in 1994 to enact NUMMI principles there. In Brazil, he had a big, unionized workforce, but he could avoid GM's bureaucracy, its supplier network, and the United Auto Workers.
马克·霍根于1994年接管通用巴西，在当地实施NUMMI原则。在巴西，他拥有一支庞大的工会化劳动力队伍，但他可以避开通用的官僚机构、供应商网络和UAW。
How long did it take you to implement the lessons of NUMMI in Brazil?
你在巴西实施NUMMI的经验花了多长时间？
It took us about 18 to 24 months, which at the time, I was quite impatient about. I mean, I wanted it faster.
我们花了大约18到24个月，当时我对此相当不耐烦。我的意思是，我想要它更快。
And what did that mean for the bottom line for GM?
这对通用的底线意味着什么？
Well, in that time frame, particularly '94 through '97, GM Brazil was one of the most profitable entities within GM.
嗯，在那个时间框架内，特别是94年到97年，通用巴西是通用内部利润最高的实体之一。
But in America, everyone I talked to said it took about a decade and a half after NUMMI for change to even begin to take hold at GM. By the year 2000, GM finally started to see a generational transformation. Jeffrey Liker says so many managers had come through NUMMI for training for a day or a week or a year.
但在美国，我交谈过的每个人都说，NUMMI之后用了大约十五年时间，变革才开始在通用真正扎根。到2000年，通用终于开始看到代际转型。杰弗里·莱克说，太多的经理通过NUMMI进行了一天、一周或一年的培训。
Over time, you start to get 10 people, 20 people, 100 people, 300 people. And you now have a critical mass of people in GM who've all been in NUMMI. They've lived it. Now they're managing people and teaching them what they learned. And it snowballs, and suddenly, the world is different at GM, and nobody can even tell you exactly why.
随着时间的推移，你开始得到10个人、20个人、100个人、300个人。你现在在通用拥有了一群都在NUMMI呆过的关键多数人。他们经历过它。现在他们正在管理人们并教授他们学到的东西。它像滚雪球一样，突然间，通用的一切都不同了，甚至没人能确切告诉你原因。
By the early 2000s, GM had developed a production model with the UAW based on Japanese principles that would go into all of its plants. It was called the Global Manufacturing System. And although GM quality still lags behind the imports, it's improved a lot. Again, Jeffrey Liker.
到21世纪初，通用基于日本原则与UAW开发了一种生产模型，将进入其所有工厂。它被称为“全球制造体系”。虽然通用质量仍然落后于进口车，但它有了很大提高。再次请出杰弗里·莱克。
If you look carefully at the quality of a GM product, and you look with a fine tooth comb, with a magnifying glass, you're going to see a level of quality that you didn't see 15 years ago.
如果你仔细观察通用产品的质量，并用细齿梳子、放大镜观察，你会看到15年前看不到的质量水平。
You want to show me for a sec? Do you mind? There's one right here.
你想给我展示一下吗？你介意吗？这里就有一辆。
I did my interview with Jeffrey Liker at the 2010 Detroit Auto Show, and we walked over to the GM exhibit, to the Cadillac SRX, which is a small SUV. Jeffrey pointed to the gap between the doors and the car frame, which is supposed to be uniform.
我在2010年底特律车展上采访了杰弗里·莱克，我们走向通用汽车展台，看向凯迪拉克SRX，这是一款小型SUV。杰弗里指着门和车架之间的缝隙，缝隙应该是均匀的。
And if we look down here, it looks really good, right? The gap is about the same between the front and the back door. The surface is very smooth and very uniform.
如果我们看看这里，它看起来真不错，对吧？缝隙在前门和后门之间基本相同。表面非常光滑且非常均匀。
And 15 years ago, what would that have looked like?
15年前，那看起来会是什么样？
You would see maybe at the top, it would be more narrow than at the bottom. If you look inside the car, and you open the glove box, it falls very gradually down the way it's supposed to. You close it-- I barely have to touch it, and it closes tightly.
你可能会看到顶部比底部更窄。如果你往车里看，打开手套箱，它会像应该的那样非常缓慢地掉下来。你关上它——我几乎不用碰它，它就紧紧地关上了。
Precision in all these details makes for a better-looking, more reliable car, where things work like they're supposed to. But this improvement didn't come soon enough. Some cars and some plants improved less quickly than others. And while GM was getting better, so were its competitors, leaving it still near the back of the pack.
所有这些细节的精确度造就了一辆看起来更好、更可靠的汽车，事情按其应有的方式运作。但这种改进来得太慢了。有些汽车和有些工厂改进得不那么快。虽然通用在变好，但其竞争对手也在变好，留给它的仍然接近垫底。
Well, one of the ironies of GM was that in the moment it went bankrupt, it was probably a better company than it had ever been.
嗯，通用的讽刺之一是，在它破产的那一刻，它可能比以往任何时候都是一家更好的公司。
That's James Womack, co-author of a seminal book comparing the Toyota and GM production systems, The Machine That Changed the World.
那是詹姆斯·沃马克，一本比较丰田和通用生产体系的开创性著作《改变世界的机器》的合著者。
In the factories, they had really dramatically closed the productivity gap that they had had for many, many years. And on the new products, they have much better quality. So the company that failed was actually doing better than it had ever done. But it was too late, and that's really sort of hard to forgive-- that if you take 30 years to figure it out, chances are you're going to get run over. And they got run over.
在工厂里，他们真的戏剧性地缩小了多年来一直存在的生产力差距。在新产品上，他们有更好的质量。所以失败的公司实际上比以往任何时候都做得更好。但太迟了，这真的很难原谅——如果你花30年才搞清楚，你很可能会被碾压。他们被碾压了。
In the end, what did them in was the 2008 recession. It destroyed the car market. The next year, General Motors became the largest industrial bankruptcy in US history. Its bailout cost taxpayers more than $50 billion. I asked Mark Hogan, the NUMMI commando who went on to run GM's small car division in North America, if GM had adopted NUMMI earlier, could it have really changed all that?
最终，让他们倒下的是2008年的经济衰退。它摧毁了汽车市场。第二年，通用汽车成为美国历史上最大的工业破产案。其救助花费了纳税人超过500亿美元。我问马克·霍根，那位后来经营通用北美小型车部门的NUMMI突击队员，如果通用更早采用NUMMI，真的能改变这一切吗？
Definitely. I think if General Motors had moved in the late '80s to implement the system across the board, it may very well have saved GM from going into bankruptcy.
肯定会。我认为如果通用汽车在80年代后期采取行动全面实施该系统，它很可能挽救通用免于破产。
Explain that.
解释一下。
Well, I just think the productivity and the quality changes that come with that would have been so profound that this ever increasing loss of market share would have been stopped.
嗯，我只是认为伴随而来的生产力和质量变化会非常深远，以至于这种不断扩大的市场份额流失会被停止。
Well, I think they'd have been building a higher quality product.
嗯，我认为他们会制造出更高质量的产品。
Again, the UAW's Bruce Lee.
再次请出UAW的布鲁斯·李。
You know, they sold junk for a while. Just any kind of piece of crap they could roll out there, they did. And they paid a tremendous price for it. And even when they turned the corner in quality, people didn't trust them.
你知道，他们卖了一段时间垃圾。只要是他们能推出来的任何烂东西，他们都做了。他们为此付出了巨大的代价。即使当他们扭转质量局面时，人们也不信任他们。
They'd say, well, gee, they're building a good car now. Why aren't they buying them? Because they don't trust them. But had they adopted and embraced the team concept in an honest way, they were going to do this, I think it might have dramatically changed what happened in the American auto industry. There's no question in my mind.
他们会说，嗯，天哪，他们现在制造好车了。为什么没人买？因为他们不信任他们。但如果他们以诚实的方式采用和拥抱团队概念，他们本来可以做到这一点，我认为这可能会戏剧性地改变美国汽车工业发生的事情。我毫无疑问。
Of course, quality and reliability weren't the only problems that brought GM down. Executives made other big mistakes. Over the years, General Motors negotiated contracts with the UAW with such generous health care coverage that by 2007, it amounted to more than $1,600 for each vehicle GM produced in North America. And initially, some GM executives dismissed hybrid cars like the Prius as a publicity stunt. Instead, they bet the company on SUVs and trucks, only to see sales crash when gas hit $4.00 a gallon.
当然，质量和可靠性并不是导致通用倒下的唯一问题。高管们犯了其他大错。多年来，通用汽车与UAW谈判达成了如此慷慨的医疗保健合同，以至于到2007年，通用在北美生产的每辆汽车为此负担超过1600美元。最初，一些通用高管把像普锐斯（Prius）这样的混合动力车贬为公关噱头。相反，他们押注公司在SUV和卡车上，结果在汽油价格达到每加仑4美元时眼睁睁看着销量崩溃。
Over the last decade, as GM became more like Toyota, Toyota became a little bit like GM. In 2008, it took over the title from GM of the world's largest automaker. But Toyota executives now say the company did this by making one of GM's old mistakes-- stressing quantity over quality.
过去十年里，随着通用变得更像丰田，丰田变得有点像通用。2008年，它从通用手中夺走了全球最大汽车制造商的头衔。但丰田高管现在说，公司这样做是犯了通用的旧错误之一——产量高于质量。
Akio Toyoda is the company CEO. He's the grandson of the founder, and cut his teeth at NUMMI. At a congressional hearing in 2010 about Toyota's sudden acceleration problems, he said the company's fatal mistake was growing too fast.
丰田章男是公司CEO。他是创始人的孙子，在NUMMI崭露头角。在2010年关于丰田突然加速问题的国会听证会上，他说公司致命的错误是发展太快。
We pursued growth over the speed at which we are able to develop our people and our organization, and I am deeply sorry for any accident that Toyota drivers have experienced.
我们追求增长的速度超过了我们培养员工和组织的能力，我对丰田驾驶员经历的任何事故深表歉意。
It was 15 years before GM took the lessons of NUMMI seriously, and it spent the next 10 years slowly implementing what it learned. And all the time, the NUMMI plant kept pumping out vehicles-- 6,000 a week on average, two shifts a day. Toyota got what it wanted out of the deal. A year after starting NUMMI, it began opening other factories around the US, using what it had learned in Fremont.
距离通用认真对待NUMMI的经验已经过去了15年，随后它又花了10年时间缓慢实施所学到的东西。一直以来，NUMMI工厂都在不停地生产车辆——平均每周6000辆，每天两班倒。丰田从这笔交易中得到了它想要的。启动NUMMI一年后，它开始在美国各地开设其他工厂，使用它在弗里蒙特学到的东西。
GM and Toyota continued to run NUMMI together until 2009, when GM went bankrupt and pulled out, leaving Toyota to run the plant alone. Toyota decided to shut the factory down. It was their only unionized plant in the United States.
通用和丰田继续共同经营NUMMI直到2009年，当时通用破产并退出，留下丰田独自经营该工厂。丰田决定关闭该工厂。这是它在美国唯一的工会工厂。
In April 2010, NUMMI produced its very last car-- a Corolla. 4,500 people lost their jobs. This is the first factory Toyota has shut down since it was founded 73 years ago.
2010年4月，NUMMI生产了它的最后一辆车——一辆卡罗拉。4500人失去了工作。这是自丰田73年前成立以来关闭的第一家工厂。
Toyota's not perfect. GM is not perfect. But I think anyone who touched NUMMI will never forget it.
丰田并不完美。通用并不完美。但我认为任何接触过NUMMI的人都不会忘记它。
One last time, that's John Shook, the first American Toyota hired for NUMMI.
最后一次，那是约翰·舒克，丰田为NUMMI聘请的第一位美国人。
It does represent something that was special at a point in time. It was a laboratory. My learning curve-- it wasn't just a curve. It was a 90 degree right angle. I loved every minute of it. And almost everyone I think you'll talk to who worked on NUMMI will say the same thing.
它确实代表了一些在特定时间点很特别的东西。它是一个实验室。我的学习曲线——它不仅仅是一条曲线。它是一个90度的直角。我热爱它的每一分钟。我认为你交谈过的每一个在NUMMI工作过的人都会说同样的话。
I'm so fortunate that I ended my career in the auto industry at NUMMI.
我非常幸运能在NUMMI结束我在汽车行业的职业生涯。
Rick Madrid retired from the assembly line in 1992.
里克·马德里于1992年从装配线上退休。
I just hate to see the plant close. Oh, that just hurts me. End of an era. It changed my life from being depressed, bored, and like my son said, changed my attitude. It changed me all for the better. I really hate to see it go.
我真的讨厌看到工厂关闭。噢，那真的伤害了我。一个时代的终结。它改变了我的生活，从抑郁、无聊到像我儿子说的，改变了我的态度。它彻底改变了我，让我变得更好。我真的讨厌看到它离开。
I look at cars, and I see a lot of the cars that we built.
我看着车，我看到了很多我们制造的车。
That's Billy Haggerty, who ended up putting in 18 years at NUMMI without a vacation day. He says just the other day he saw one.
那是比利·哈格蒂，他在NUMMI工作了18年，一天假都没请。他说就在前几天他看到了一个。
But I just seen-- what was it? An '86, '87 Corolla pull in right around the corner here. I was heading for the bank. And I just looked at it and said, boy, that one's old. And I looked down, and it was a Corolla.
但我刚才看到——是什么？一辆86年、87年的卡罗拉转弯过来。我正要去银行。我只是看了一眼说，孩子，那辆车真老。我往下看，那是卡罗拉。
I know we built it right there. So it's still running. It's still kicking. It feels good.
我知道我们在那里制造了它。所以它还在跑。它还在踢。感觉真好。
This is also NUMMI's legacy. In the end, it's not just a symbol for so many things that went wrong with GM. It's also a really good car plant. One that turned out nearly 8 million high-quality cars and trucks.
这也是NUMMI的遗产。最终，它不仅是通用汽车出错的许多事情的象征。它也是一个真正好的汽车工厂。它制造了近800万辆高质量的汽车和卡车。
Frank Langfitt. When we first ran this story back in 2010, Frank was NPR's automotive correspondent. He's now their international correspondent based in Shanghai. Since 2010, the NUMMI plant in Fremont has become symbolic of what's happening in the American car industry in a different way. It's now where they make the Tesla.
弗兰克·朗菲特。当我们在2010年第一次播出这个故事时，弗兰克是NPR的汽车记者。他现在是他们驻上海的国际记者。自2010年以来，位于弗里蒙特的NUMMI工厂以另一种方式成为了美国汽车工业正在发生的事情的象征。现在那里生产特斯拉。
[MUSIC - "TOYOTA COROLLA," THE TURN UPS]
[音乐 - “丰田卡罗拉”，THE TURN UPS]
Frank Langfitt's story about NUMMI was produced by me and Brian Reed. NPR's Uri Berliner helped us edit it. Our show today was produced by Lisa Pollak, with Alex Blumberg, Jane Feltes, Sarah Koenig, Robyn Semien, Alyssa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer for today's show is Julie Snyder. Production help from Simon Adler and Lilly Sullivan.
弗兰克·朗菲特关于NUMMI的故事由我和布莱恩·里德制作。NPR的尤里·伯林纳帮助我们编辑了它。我们今天的节目由丽莎·波拉克制作，亚历克斯·布隆伯格、简·费尔特斯、萨拉·凯尼格、罗宾·塞米恩、艾丽莎·希普和南希·厄普代克参与。我们今天节目的高级制片人是朱莉·斯奈德。西蒙·阿德勒和莉莉·沙利文提供了制作帮助。
Seth Lind is our operations director. Emily Condon's our production manager. Elise Bergerson's our business manager. Kimberly Henderson is our office coordinator. Old Japanese TV footage in today's show comes from NHK in Tokyo. Thanks to [INAUDIBLE], who translated it for us.
塞斯·林德是我们的运营总监。艾米丽·康登是我们的制片经理。埃利斯·伯格森是我们的商务经理。金伯利·亨德森是我们的办公室协调员。今天节目中旧的日本电视录像来自东京NHK。感谢[听不清]为我们翻译了它。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
Since we first broadcast this story in 2010, a number of the people who Frank interviewed have since died, including Rick Madrid, the guy who would go around putting postcards in the windshields of old Chevy Novas. Our website, www.thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
自2010年我们第一次播出这个故事以来，弗兰克采访的一些人已经去世了，包括里克·马德里，那个到处把明信片塞进旧雪佛兰Nova挡风玻璃的家伙。我们的网站，www.thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由PRX，公共广播交换台提供给公共广播电台。
Since we first broadcast this story in 2010, a number of the people who Frank interviewed have since died, including Rick Madrid the guy who would go around putting postcards in the windshields of old Chevy Novas. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
自2010年我们第一次播出这个故事以来，弗兰克采访的一些人已经去世了，包括里克·马德里，那个到处把明信片塞进旧雪佛兰Nova挡风玻璃的家伙。《美国生活》由PRX，公共广播交换台提供给公共广播电台。
Support for This American Life comes from Nest. The new Nest Protect. Smoke and carbon monoxide alarm speaks up to tell where the danger is, and it sends out a mobile alert in case nobody's home. Nest Protect is available at nest.com.
《美国生活》的支持来自Nest。新的Nest Protect。烟雾和一氧化碳报警器会发出声音告知危险在哪里，如果在没人的情况下，它会发出手机警报。Nest Protect可在nest.com购买。
And from Lagunitas Brewing Company, committed to keeping the pub in public radio by offering curious ales and lagers for those who appreciate hearing and telling great stories. Learn more at lagunitas.com
以及来自Lagunitas酿酒公司，致力于通过为那些欣赏聆听和讲述伟大故事的人提供好奇的啤酒和拉格啤酒，保持公共广播的酒吧文化。在lagunitas.com了解更多。
And from Hulu, now offering full access to Showtime, including current and past seasons of original series, movies, and more, all without commercials. Learn more about Showtime access and a one month trial at hulu.com.
以及来自Hulu，现在提供对Showtime的全面访问，包括原创剧集、电影等的当前和过去季度，全部没有广告。在hulu.com了解更多关于Showtime访问和一个月试用。
Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, I overheard him in the hallway, telling somebody how surprised he was about the quality of our programs this past year.
像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人，托雷·马拉蒂亚先生。你知道，我在走廊里无意中听到他告诉某人，他对过去一年我们节目的质量感到多么惊讶。
Because that was not a young workforce. And, you know, they were old. They were fat.
因为那不是一支年轻的劳动力队伍。而且，你知道，他们老了。他们胖了。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。